good morning believe nation today's
message is stand up over to you Patrick
since young the challenge that faces you
are various dogma now let me talk a
little bit about dogma and I face dogma
all my life as Yana said I'm a surgeon
scientist maybe engineer I was born in
South Africa as a Chinese American came
to this country as an American so I have
no idea what I am frankly but I think
what's important is to be persistent to
really dream your dream feel and stand
up to what you really believe in I love
this message because people will expect
you to do things in your life based on
your family background your education
your cultural background your beliefs
the neighborhood that you grew up in the
friends that you have everybody has a
perception of where you should go in
life and what you should be doing right
your family wants you to do something
your friends think you're capable of
doing certain amount of things and every
now and then we get a boldness within us
to want to go and do something that's
out of the norm to do something that
nobody's done before to break the mold
to be the first to go to university in
our family be the first entrepreneur in
our neighborhood and a lot of times
those dreams get crushed they get
crushed because you have this
environment around you that pulls you
back to where you are and it takes a
great deal of courage to stand up and
want to be something different I'm
really grateful to my parents because
nobody in my family was really an
entrepreneur my parents both had kind of
safe stable jobs and here I was wanted
to go off and be an entrepreneur and
they didn't have guidance for me on how
to be successful as an entrepreneur but
they always encouraged me to do what I
believed in they always made me believe
that whatever I wanted to do they would
tell me I'm a cost really Carmichael
I can do whatever I wanted and they
always encourage my dreams even though
they couldn't always give me kind of
practical advice and guidance and next
steps and what to do so I really
encourage you if you find the thing that
you want to do if it's different than
everybody else believe in it stand up
for it chase it because you have to at
the end of the day decide whether you're
going to be living your version of your
life or somebody else's version of your
life bully so the question the day today
is what do you stand up for leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso